foreign
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
you know how many people [ __ ] they go
everyone says I got a buddy just like a
Tommy yeah
me and my brothers are like you had a
Tommy and a Joe and an Ari oh my God I
don't know why you're doing a racist
Pizzeria
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I did the best one was I did a sober
October with the you guys
and then his girlfriend she goes he
didn't last the first day
I was picturing a guy in lederhosen
with a big mug of beer yeah I'm an Asian
supremacist all the way I mean I love I
love Asians yeah
um I've never dated an Asian chick I
always wish I had I've I've hooked up
with a few but uh I never dated one
because they're always working
hey ho
um this is so bad I was like I wrote a
joke one time do you think uh Papa
Smurf's middle name is boner Papa boner
Smurf I was like that was my that was
the best joke writing I could do I have
sciatica what's that again uh
yeah you got it too yes I'm guessing
yeah what yeah
pain in your ass cheek just randomly
yeah I got prison sciatica
I did it a black chick named sciatica
she was a pain in my ass
for writing that was a thousand people
in there
what is it like to go out there
to over a thousand screaming people in
another continent that you're like
like just you at what point do you go
how the [ __ ] these people even know who
I am you know what I mean yeah well the
one word Rogan yeah
but it's all him I mean he's the he's
the draw so it's pretty crazy I know but
it's I think it's it's I don't I think
there's a um
I think your initial walkout is great
then once you start you're just like oh
I'm in Cleveland right yeah yeah that's
a good thing it doesn't feel yeah it
feels very like American as an audience
here it doesn't feel like you don't see
like uh I don't know like top hats and
the way you'd expect it there's like a
bunch of [ __ ] Orphans yeah
he's off the top balcony there was this
porn star Jesse Andrews do you know who
she is she was awesome she's not porn
star anymore she's a DJ yeah
there's a lot of porn stars that are DJs
now well it's an easy transition because
it's a skillless job what do you mean
yeah
are you GJ
are you a DJ no porn star oh
I got a crazy day I'm pitching a TV show
right after this at TBS and then I'm
doing another pitch after that with
Comedy Central nice uh
uh if it's
give me some name I need an intro I got
nothing going in
um don't ever let them talk first you
just start talking you just go in and
you run the room you run the room I took
your advice again on pitching you're
like you gotta own the room coming hot
you know take no prisoners and I don't
want to say what network it is because
I'll probably get sued or something but
I'm trying to be funny we couldn't get
the video to work and uh the guy was
like what is this like oh it's the Kevin
Hart sex tape and he goes oh can you
believe he's getting sued for that I'm
like well it's the funniest thing he's
ever done and the guy goes actually I
produced the last four of those and I
was like you just Stone faced eye
contact said that and I was like oh I'm
Joe I mean I'm joking I you know I like
Kevin Hart
I've just [ __ ] heard their [ __ ] the
back pedaling back pedaling and he's
like yeah you didn't like him or you
don't you don't think they're funny on
this they're on this network that you're
trying I'm just like yeah yeah and then
we pitched after that it was the worst
pitch ever brutal and my agents were
like you [ __ ] us that was bro what are
you doing I was like I was trying to be
funny but I feel like if someone was
watching that from an audience they'd be
like this is great so uh we go to we go
to Bourbon Street you know a couple
local kids yucking it up and uh this is
before cell phones really so it's me and
I think five guys and two guys go we
just got fake IDs we're gonna go get
Daiquiris daiquiris in New Orleans are a
big thing and we're like all right and
we just lose them that was it they were
just gone yeah boom that's that was the
90s and uh that was the 90s people would
just disappeared it just disappeared you
lost them we're like where'd they go oh
[ __ ] we looked around for 10 minutes and
they were gone [ __ ] it so then uh then
now it's being two friends and we're
walking around this woman is on the on
the balcony flashing which is pretty you
know par for the course but she was kind
of hot and just flashing freely she had
a leather jack with no shirt under it I
remember it was pretty hot and she
looked kind of like a like a Jennifer
Aniston after a fist fight I'd say and
uh we keep staring at her and she goes
she looks down and goes you guys want to
come up and we're like [ __ ] yeah you
know let's do it how old is she I'd say
45. oh wow yeah but she looked good
still she was hanging in there and she'd
seen a few women enters but you know she
was hanging and uh so we go we try to go
over the Ramada hotel we try to go up
and the guy goes you can't come in if
you're not a guest so we go back we look
up or they won't let us in she goes I'm
coming down we're like oh my God you
know as a kid back then is it a teenage
no no adult gave you the time of day so
this is crazy that she's talking to us
so she comes down
she's very maternal like how you kids
doing you guys want to come out and
throw some beads you're feeling good
we're like oh this woman doesn't want to
do anything yeah and uh so my friend is
like nudging me he was like just say
something just ask her what's what you
got to lose so I just go hey look lady I
don't I don't want to go on a 2000 a
virgin and she puts her hand on my
shoulder and goes well I won't let you
and I was like oh my God so she's like
she brings us into the hotel she goes uh
puts us in the elevator and she says go
to room 239 and then the doors close
she's not in there and we just go oh my
God
just a bunch of 16 year old Joe oh my
God we're punch each other on the
shoulder headlocks oh my God so we got
out of the elevator we go to room 239 we
wait 10 minutes 20 minutes 30 minutes
we're like what the [ __ ] we're just
sitting on the floor now finally she
walks up I don't know what she was doing
finally she walks up she opens the door
there's an old man with a white beard
and a Harley Davidson hat and a leather
jacket just sitting in a chair staring
at the door and uh he goes which one is
it and she goes him she points to me and
he goes all right and we're like what
the [ __ ] is this and she goes he goes
you two the old guy goes YouTube come
out on the balcony I got a I got a case
of beer out there in a cooler and my
friends are like uh should we go and I'm
like yeah just go [ __ ] it whatever so
they go outside he closes the French
doors behind him she walks up and shuts
the blinds so they're out there and
they're out they're out of my life so
now
she's like uh all right so how do you
want to do this and I was you know young
cocky kid I go well take a [ __ ] first
and she goes I don't give blow jobs and
I remember saying you pick up kids off
the street but you don't get [ __ ]
she didn't like that and uh she goes uh
anything else and I go what are you
clean she goes do you want to do this or
not I was like all right sorry I was
such a douchebag I didn't know what to
say that's my first time
never been [ __ ] never been blown
whatever so I remember she said you
wanna you make yourself a little more
comfortable and I said all right I had a
jacket on a button down and an
undershirt I took the jacket off you
know and I'm laying on a bed in jeans
and she's like well I'm gonna go in the
bathroom for a second she comes out
completely naked with just socks on him
or being like Oh my God a naked woman it
was it was crazy good body great body
she had the uh the ski slopes like the
banana tits that was kind of weird but
uh they were fine and uh she had the
worst breath in the world too I remember
but uh we're going at it and she goes
you have a condom and just like out of a
movie I had the condom from the 40s you
know yeah and she's like uh hang on she
opened nightstand drawer it's just Lube
dildos condoms French ticklers vibrators
I was like oh my God what am I getting
into and she she put the condom on me
and I remember I put my put my dick
through the boxer hole because I was too
nervous about her seeing my balls for
some reason yeah I don't know why yeah
and we [ __ ] for hours maybe like two
hours I never came I was too nervous
what do you mean you never came I never
came I was just so like Blown Away the
whole time but I never finished and uh
she after it I think because she's I was
a younger guy I could last and she was
like we got to do this again I was like
I can I can't she's like come on what
are you doing tomorrow and I I had this
wave of shame I was like I gotta get the
hell out of here and uh I opened the
door to the balcony my friends fall in
they're hammered and they're one of my
friends goes I got sloppy seconds I'm
like dude I'm just yanking them out we
we get the hell out of there we go to my
friend's house we pass out and uh the
phone rings like 7 A.M and I answer the
phone which is that's very 90s too as a
landline I'm answering my friend's phone
he would never see that down yeah so I
answered my friend's phone and it's my
two friends we lost and they're go
you're not gonna believe what happened
to me I'm like you're not gonna believe
what happened to me and they go we've
met these two swimmers from UCLA we
[ __ ] him and I'm like I [ __ ] a [ __ ]
and she didn't charge me so I kind of
want everyone to watch my hour and give
me notes
right it's like I'm gonna be doing stand
up I'm gonna be like tell can you please
just just I'm getting ready to shoot on
Netflix by November can you just watch
this set tell me where I'm lazy you
don't have to give me jokes tell me
where I'm lazy tell me where I'm [ __ ]
sloppy he's gonna Crush you though
because he's so honest I don't know you
got anything on uh Putin and I tell him
the joke he's like oh yeah yeah wait
what did you jump on Putin I just had a
whole thing about how he's 5'7 he knows
Jujitsu and he's bald he's like the
Russian Joe Rogan although Putin said
the N word he wouldn't apologize and it
hits but he was like can I tell you a
joke yeah okay uh Neil Young walks into
a bar
all right I'm already laughing in the
bar he sees Joe Rogan sitting at the bar
and he Stomps his foot and starts to
walk out and Joe goes hey Neil
sit down man let me buy you a drink we
can talk this out we're grown-ups we're
artists let's talk you know sits down
and he says all right
I'm game
uh what do you have and Joe says I'm
having a beer the shots are no good
I've worked that joke that took me a
second that's great yeah something no
good I told it to Leanne and she goes
all right is he an alcoholic
I told it to Tommy on two bears and if I
told it for real yeah I told the way I
tell a story like where I go oh my God I
talked to Joe last night and I told him
oh that's good yeah did he laugh uh he
didn't get it I don't think a get rich
quick schemes but I I fantasize about
things I can do that will sell tickets
like a plane crash and I rescue people I
think about that all the time I used to
think about that one getting laid like
all right maybe I'll set up a fake
robbery and then I'll beat the guy up
and then she'll blow me
um but yeah I do do that like I always
want to save the day somehow and have it
go news viral you know like comedian
loser comedian uh with small penis saves
old lady from getting raped you know
here's the question though do you
mention you're like say you saved the
day uh news crews show up
they go hey can we talk to you for a
second do you say hey guys uh I got a
show in Sacramento this coming week for
those who don't know are listening John
Manns has been on tour with me he was my
shooter for Trip Flip and he was also my
shooter for birth conquer Mance is
getting himself in camera say hello
manzi and so uh I'll give you a few
quick stories his uh his stepfather uh
mans grew up at like 10 000 feet
elevation and one night his stepfather
made had made honey and one night his
stepfather found a bear in his honey and
so he chased the bear out of his honey
and all of a sudden the wires turned
around and chased him
like Benny Hill
chasing the bear and then you see the
bear
these are my favorite man Stories the
bear was just like wait a second I'm a
[ __ ] band
that sounds like a euphemism God I came
home there was a bear in my honey that
sounds like he came home was a black guy
[ __ ] my wife
because they know John really well and
I'll go did Jennifer tell you about the
time he was a ninja and got arrested and
they're like wait what he's Asian
I wouldn't know what to do now yeah well
booze is the booze is like 80 of it can
you start drinking because for me the
hard part was because I just wanted to
[ __ ] him yeah you know I hate to be that
guy but I'm like I just want to [ __ ] you
you're I just want to make love to you
lady come on with the talking how many
times can you go oh yeah get out of here
you're in sales come on what do you
create you hate your mom I know I get it
uh your cats you love that cat how many
times can you do that you know listen to
this [ __ ] man so I've been texting with
Seinfeld and you know we've been going
back forward we're actually building a
little bit of a relation and uh I'm such
a chisler cheap [ __ ] that I bought a new
phone off Craigslist because I went to
the app store they're like that's about
1200 bucks so there was like 1200 bucks
that's crazy so I find some fat Mexican
guy we show up he shows up to First
Avenue I get it for 300 bucks it's a
decent looking phone I lose everything
immediately I lose all my numbers I have
to go bother people for every everything
and then I'm at a comedy condo in
Charlotte hungover at seven in the
morning there's no curtains so the sun's
coming at night can't sleep went out all
night I get a text and it says uh from
Jerry Seinfeld goes hey man is this
number still good and I go oh well
what's up man what did I miss sorry hey
it's been a crazy week and he goes I've
been trying to contact you I'm like holy
hell I've been blowing off Jerry
unknowingly and I'm like yeah yeah he's
your guy I know I know and I was like
what's up sorry he's like here just text
my manager I I I'm he was a little
peeved so he gave me the manager's
number and I called him and he's like
where the hell you been we've been
looking for you I was like oh man I got
a new phone so that just that's a lesson
for the kids out there don't skimp get
the [ __ ] phone I missed everything I
lost all those picks I had all these
beautiful Europe picks so wait what did
uh did you trade the phone for the
Mexican guy no I just bought the phone
from him I think he stole a phone from
like a 7-Eleven or something and so wait
so what what happened with Jerry are you
doing again I'm doing some gigs with him
yeah thank God he tried again you know
he's gonna try again kind of guy he
doesn't need to what's he like uh pretty
normal normal I mean he's he's uh I hope
he never hears this but he's like I tell
it like it is kind of guy like he's one
of those guys where you go yeah I got a
pool it's kind of like a peanut and he's
like no no it's shaped like a peanut
it's not like a shape like you know he
said he was one of the first people to
come out and say I think I might be
autistic yeah he did the Spectrum thing
back before it was cool back before it
was like a way to sell a special right
now I'm up it's good to be back
so wait let's uh let's let's uh let's
talk through the night last night yeah
big night show was amazing ripped it I
went on had a hot one
intermission drank more Bert went on
ripped it and uh then we went to the bar
I think I was looking for a little more
than just oh really what happened bullet
points Jesus
thanks Mark all right podcast is over
guys
just put about a PowerPoint display
while you're right here's my friend said
you're not born gay you heard this joke
and he goes really he goes yeah it's a
decision it's a decision Nick and Nick
goes are you gay and he goes no he goes
but you're you're saying you can get
talked into it
I didn't know Patrice but I'd watched
him a few times and I was a huge fan but
I saw one time uh this guy went up to
him and he was wearing like a yellow
like raincoat and he just goes hey
Patrice buddy he was a comic I didn't
know who he was but he was like Hey
Patrice what's chicken buddy and Patrice
man get your fish stick ass out of here
what was the guy uh Mr Gordon is it yeah
he said get your Mr Gordon fish stick
asset and I was like oh my God it's
hilarious but I could never do it I
could never say hi to him I'm too too
nervous well I didn't know her but I
knew that she was blowing up and I said
hi and she was like oh hi you want a
picture or something she didn't know who
you were no I should know who I was I
guess your shirt was on well what cause
you know we all love Tommy but uh
where'd this come from he's been kind of
quiet and been kind of behaved after the
[ __ ] scandal
which is a great new show on a e
check it out it's after Law and Order
Red Rocks we're doing Red Rocks together
baby there's a reason Mark Norman's
coming everywhere with me Red Rocks Red
Rock the other r words
foreign
[Music]